Good evening.
So we finish every evening with prayer and
I love hearing your praying together as micro groups,
but it hits me that we're not really started our evening
with prayer. And so I want to start our evening with prayer
this evening. Okay, let's pray father. Thank you so much for the
opportunity to be a part of something powerful Transcendent
and holy and I
pray Lord you would show us exactly. What is our role as it
comes to making disciples. Thank you
for those that are willing to give time up to learn and
discover. Just what you've called them to do and bless them
for it and I just pray that the spirit
would continue to work in our micro groups as
we discuss this wonderful opportunity in Jesus
name. Amen.
All right, so we are talking about disciple making and I
want to do a little bit of review. This is our pathway and
oops. I forgot my pencil. Excuse me.
This is our pathway. And by the way in the
coming.
Weeks and I don't know exactly when we're
gonna do this in the coming weeks. I'm gonna
have one of you guys come and do exactly what I've done. This
will be my fourth time. I've done this and I
want you to become so familiar with it that you can do it. So what
what the discipleship pathway
is is that everything is pointing people towards becoming
not only a disciple of Jesus one
who is a growing and knows Jesus
follows. Jesus being transformed by Changed by
Jesus and committed the mission of Jesus, but
Also someone who is reproducing
themselves, so that that happens
we become disciple makers as
soon as we come to know the Lord Jesus, we're Disciples
of Jesus, but and we
worship together and that's a good thing to do. But that's there's some
things that are limited as it pertains to our sitting and facing the
same direction and listening to one person speak.
And I'll use an example
like this my wife and I when we first started dating, we we
would talk back and forth.
What do you think would have happened?
And see I'm making this up as I'm going along
so I gotta be really careful. What do you think would have happened
if I was the only one Speaking?
Like we would go out on today and I said well, I'm just glad you're here.
I've got so much to tell you about myself. I'm I grew up in the you know,
and I did all the talking and she never spoke. Do
you think we would date a second time?
No, no and the same would be true if she spoke the whole time.
But what we did is I would speak and listen and she would
speak and then listen and we would and that's how we got to know one another.
Well, that's exactly what happens in this pathway. We
have large equipping groups next week. We'll be
our fifth week and we'll actually not be meeting
as a disciple making 101 training group. This
will be a week off
and we will be looking at Family equipping
Ministry what that means is that the primary
disciple maker in a family is the parents
and the parents are partnering with the Henderson Hills Baptist
Church to raise Little Disciples. And so we'll be
talking about that next week. And so we'll be
taking one week pause but that's an example
of the equipping group, but it's pointing people where we
have
Community groups a great way to increase our
strength as disciples but but we've
been focusing this on Wednesday nights at
this is our sweet spot right here micro groups
where we can
Where we can learn about what it means
to be a have an intentional leader. And by the way, no, don't
get this wrong. All right
hear me out my prayer is and I've got
other groups praying now that one day you
Look down at your first button right there.
That's what that's the one I'm talking about. You will
be an intentional leader that you are
already beginning to pray about God. Who would
you have me invite to be in my
micro group and what you'll do
with that person is then you two will create
a relational environment where you can get
together and hear one another and you can do what my
wife and I did when we create a relationship you speak and then
listen and they speak and then listen and then eventually once
you have a a certain degree
of spiritual strength, then
you reproduce yourself so that
now that person becomes an intentional leader
and creates a relational environment with another
person and that's how exponential multiplication occurred
and that's why Jesus said he wanted it the way
he wanted it. All right. So what is a disciple?
Disciple is one who is following Jesus being changed
by Jesus and committed to the mission of
Jesus making disciples. I would love for you to memorize that
and so when I have you come up here and present this to
the correct crowd in a couple of weeks, you'll you'll nail
it and you won't have to read it. Okay, I've shown
you this graph. It's a little X Y axis graph
that here in our
worship center.
During our worship service. We have beautiful worship music. We
have a profoundly prepared and delivered sermon,
but we don't get to respond. And if
we do people think that we're crazy and sometimes
the ushers.
Escort us out if we don't be
quiet, but but what happens here is as we
grow increasingly smaller in size.
We have a better opportunity for conversation.
and
intimacy
This is by exactly what happened with me and my wife that
we would be transparent. Oops going back
transparent.
I can't believe I'm telling this story, but I remember where I
was standing on.
The sidewalk in front of her parents house when she
told me she loved me for the first time.
What yeah, some of you like that and others are saying you've
got to stop stay with the curriculum.
But I remember when she told me she loved me and and that didn't
just happen because I talked the whole time but we
it was given take and she was listening and I
was listening to her and I was pouring into
her you've heard people say that I was letting her in to see
who I was and she was letting me and and she
thought hey, I really like this guy to the point. I think I'm
gonna tell him I love him. So and look what happened 42 years later. I'm telling
stories in front of everybody. All right, and then eventually
accountability.
Accountability is is a big help
in the disciples life when you
are in a micro group, and it's a
gender-based micro group. You have the opportunity to share your
fears.
to share your failures
To share your your hopes for
what God is going to be doing with you and through you
and in you.
And you might not have that opportunity in a
community group. You could if your community
group was the right environment but a lot of times because it's
an open group. Sometimes people don't share to that level
of intimacy, but that's what we're trying to create. That is what an
intentional leader is trying to create. All right,
so
Now we're moving. If you will open
up your curriculum to page four of week four.
We're looking at chapter 4
of our book invest in a few and this
is answering the question a three dimensions of what
what is a disciple how to identify a
disciple and here's the first one are they becoming like
Jesus and what that means is
is again going back to our definition.
Is this disciple one who is following Jesus being changed by
Jesus and committed to the mission of Jesus?
Well, let's let's talk about what that means. Exactly. Are
they becoming like Jesus. Think about this Jesus in
his high Priestly prayer in John 17,
praise for himself.
Praise for his disciples and while
he's praying for his disciples in verse 17. He says
this sanctify now, this is Jesus praying a
prayer about you and me
about what he's hoping will happen for
us.
He says sanctify them in the truth.
Your word is truth.
So we have access to the way the truth
and life in Jesus, but we also have access to
the truth. That is God's revealed word. And
so he's saying sanctify them.
In the truth for your word is truth. And then you talk
about living scent as you sent me into
the world. So I have sent them into the
world. So there's a lot of things happening in that verse. First of
all is Jesus prayer for us?
Secondly, he had defines what it means. I want
them to be set apart for a special purpose. That's what sanctification means
to means to be set apart for God's special
use and purpose.
And there are two primary areas according to
Craig Etheridge two primary areas where disciple
needs to be set apart for God's special use and purpose and
that's this the inner character and we're going to Define what
that means and the core competencies and
we're going to Define what that means too. First of all the inner
character. The inner character is having
Christ likeness inside of
me.
My personal personal and precisely
accurate opinion. Is this that
your faith should be demonstrated from
the inside out?
Sometimes when we get that upside down and our faith
is demonstrated from the outside and we can become legalistic. We
can become Pious we can become
unlike Christ even doing the
things that Christ has asked us to do even using core
competencies that will be talking about in a minute. I'm thinking
about the story in
the New Testament when the
when the Pharisees said dear God, I thank you
that I'm not like these other sinners.
right
And then Jesus said within there was a sinner who beat his
breast and he said Lord God be merciful to me.
I'm a sinner and Jesus said, who do you think you know?
Who do you think was the right person in the situation? So even when
we are experiencing the core competencies if we don't have
the Inside Out inner character of
Christ than our hearts can be out of whack and
in doing so then we become something less and
maybe even opposite of what a real disciple is for
example.
In the inner character of Christ Paul said to the Philippian
people Let each of you look not only on his own interests,
but also on the interest of others look at this having this
mind among yourselves, which
is yours in Christ Jesus, so we
are to have the mind of Christ and
so as his thoughts are my thoughts.
As his perspective is my perspective as his point
of view is my point of view.
As his attitude the thing
about Philippians 2 for a second.
Let this first verse one says
let this attitude be in you which is also in Christ
Jesus.
Okay, so it's even the attitude of Christ is your attitude
and
And then of course the the fruits of the spirit in Galatians
5:22, this is also part of the inner character
of Christ. You've heard of the fruits of the spirit love joy peace,
patience kindness goodness, faithfulness gentleness
and self-control. Let's just do a real
quick. We don't we
don't have to do this. But but I think it's kind of fun. Let's just
do a little
Personal confession we'll call this group confession. How
many of you could use a little bit more patience. Anyway, I
see that hand. It's like a billy cram Crusade. I
see that hand. I see that hand how many of it
could use a little bit more kindness.
All right, maybe a few less how many
of it could be a little bit more use a
little bit more to self-control and if you've done three in
a row, you could use himself control right? But no
this is the this is the fruit
of the Holy Spirit against such things.
There is no law. That means is that if we're controlled and
in step with the spirit then we don't
need the law of God reminding us of what's sinful as sinful.
We are we we're free from that because we're
full of the Holy Spirit and walking and keeping in step
with the spirit. Let's go on and those who belong to
Christ. Jesus have crucified the flesh with its passions and
desires and this is a great way of
thinking in terms of the inner character of Christ.
The heart of Christ if we live by
the spirit, let us also keep step with
the spirit. How many of you remember the term my
walk with Christ?
Right. That's it's a great term. I don't know I won't
use it anymore, but I'm walking.
in step with a spirit
the direction that Christ is calling me to walk with his
attitude with his mind with his
perspective with his thoughts my thoughts
and so that's the inner character. All right, and then
here's a from your author
Craig Etheridge a disciple is growing in these areas of
inner character learning day by
day to let the spirit of God control them change them
and lead them. So what's the goal
of discipleship? It's transformation.
And what is it? How do we Define a disciple one who's
following Jesus one who's being changed by Jesus? And so
we're being changed in our inner character and then
lastly the disciple must develop the core competencies.
And core competencies are having Christ
likeness on the outside and what that means is is
that Jesus trained his disciples and
God's word throughout the gospels. He quoted the scriptures over
70 times. So think about
when he was a 12 year old, right and I'm
laughing because it's not
happened at Henderson Hills for me yet. But every church I've served
at about 12:31 o'clock.
You see a little dude. He's about
seven.
And he's walking through the Halls kind of by himself.
And you're like hey, buddy.
Where's your parents and the little guy goes?
And Mama thought daddy took him home and daddy thought
Mama looking and they left him a church.
Right and that's happened a few times. Not at Henderson
Hills yet. Well same thing happened Jesus, but when they come back
to get him, he's in the temple with the Pharisees
talking about the Bible.
And I love this those of you that are
having trouble with your teenagers.
Mary said what are you trying to do to us?
And he asks didn't you know I'd be about
my father's business.
So one of jesus' core competencies is
training his disciples in God's word and probably
the most successful experience I've
had in micro groups is where we
use the scripture as the text. I don't
have any problem with going through a specific book. In fact,
we're probably going to provide some books for those of you who start a
brand new discipleship group Navigators has
got some great work growing in Christ designed for
discipleship lifeways got a great work called knowing God
will provide those things for you out there. You can order them your sales
but perhaps my favorite thing to do is to
say to the micro group. Let's read through the book
of blank together Book of John together this
week. We'll look at chapter one. We're gonna really really
work on chapter one and we'll come back together. We'll
discuss it together and in doing so
you may have more knowledge about the scripture than those that
you are in a disability Group with you're just sharing with them how
to not just read the scripture.
But read it in the right context and then let the
scripture read you so that you know, which questions to
ask that are probing questions and you basically are
as a group of men or women seeking collectively
to find out what is God saying to
us in this passage together and in doing so
you're learning the core competency of God's word scripture
engagement. I've included in
your notes of five different ways that you can study the
scripture read the scripture. Listen to the scripture preached
memorize the scripture you can meditate on
the scripture, but the best way to get to know the scripture
is what
Obey the scripture so you can
look at that at another time the second thing that a core
competency Jesus also trained his disciples how
to pray sometimes Jesus would pray all night
before big decisions or when facing heavy pressures of ministry. If
you ever felt
like I'm not ready for this to be a disciple maker.
Think about the time when Jesus was
In the bottom of the boat asleep, the disciples are
upstairs fighting the storm.
Right and what where's Jesus? He's downstairs
sleep.
And then what does Jesus say when
he comes back up and he says peace be still.
and but he also says
where was your faith?
Where was your faith?
And so you're probably sitting here today saying where's my face? I don't even know
if I won't do this this option thing. Well, I'll say look you just like Jesus
disciples, right? It's it's really
who's the who's the teacher the holy spirit's the
teacher?
And what's the text Will the Bible is the text. We won't
spend a lot of time on this but two other core competencies
that Jesus shared was communicating the
gospel. He modeled public and personal evangelism
and he sent out his disciples two
by two to do the same thing. The kingdom of God is near
But he also trained his disciples how to invest their
lives and others to make disciples as he made
Disciples of them. And so and they did that and and literally
turned the world upside down doing so so
here's the maximum that I want you to memorize
this week last week. We said the holy spirit is the teacher this week.
I want you to memorize the Bible as the curriculum.
Okay, there's lots of great curriculum out there.
I don't have any real problem with that that I think is theologically
sound but but hopefully you'll
get to where you guys are discussing the scripture and
you're learning from the scripture and you're you're a
holy one another accountable to read the scripture together
and you're enjoying it together.
Let's let's keep going.
All right. I had a discussion with a guy
earlier today and he wanted me and
I agree with him a hundred percent. He wanted me to clarify that you
don't actually become a disciple over on this stage.
All right.
But what you are is now you are a intentional disciple
leader in this stage. So but these
this is the disciple making
stages if you will and
last week we talked about is a is a man
of or a woman devoted a crisis because they have been born
again. And now what are they their spiritual infants?
What this tool is this is not a theological Treatise
on salvation theology. All right, this is
basically just a graphic to help you see
where you are in this disciple making Journey. Okay,
when we first are born again,
we are infant Christians a baby Christians
and as cute as we are we don't want to stay that
way. All right. So the second
stage is a spiritual child. What is it about a spiritual child?
Well, they're self-focused.
They they attend a church based upon
what the church can do for them?
they when they read scripture they're saying what is this passage saying
to me and and in doing
so it's kind of like
I've got granddaughters and they're just as cute as they
can be but they're selfish just like their mother.
And I know that because I raised their mother that's my daughter
right and you know why she's selfish because she's
just like her daddy, right? So but what
happens is they don't they don't stay as selfish as
they are when their children. Hopefully they grow out of that.
And if they don't you can see there's a real problem with immaturity, but
that's what we're hoping. Is
that eventually because of our involvement with
the people of God and the Church of God and the and the
word of God, then we grow out of our self-focusedness now
to more of a kingdom Focus where others
focused we begin to for the first time thinking in
terms of how can I serve and how can I share and what
can I do to be a part of what God is doing with this
family? Okay. And then what I'm
asking you to do is to to not just
thinking in terms of other Focus, but let's be specific about becoming
an intentional discipleship May
a disciple maker and intentional leader
creating a relational environment
and eventually reproducing
that I want to finish with a text that
I got this morning. I'm not going to read it to you because I don't have permission to do that. But I'm
sitting on the back porch I do this.
All Summer Long
All right, I get up before it gets too hot. I have a cup
of coffee in my Bible.
And so that's when I do my scripture reading and
and out of nowhere. I get this text from A
discipleship group that I
was involved in in North Dallas.
And I've told you that story well there still meeting
and they were they refuse to take me off the text stream and I
don't disagree because I like seeing what's going on with these guys.
Well, one of them broke away from our
group and started his his own group.
And it didn't go as well as he'd hoped.
Because he remembers how God moved in
this discipleship group and he's waiting to see God
move in this new discipleship micro group and
it's just not happening and they're having a good time and
you know guys breakfast coffee yucking
it up telling stories football games that kind of thing. He's just
not
Appreciating it. He's like no, we we want to
create a relational environment. We want to study God's word. We want to challenge one
another we want to hold one another accountable. How about them Cowboys? You
know, and so he he decides I'm
going back to my first group you guys
can keep doing whatever it is you're doing right and so
I was a little disappointed about that, but I'm an
Edmund now, so I was getting over it.
Well this morning I'm having my Bible study and I'm spending
time with the Lord and I see one
of the guys from his new group
a text him using a group text which
by the way is a tremendous way of in you
know.
Upping your clout. It's not just you
privately. He goes. Hey, how come we're on meeting anymore?
And and I I see Rusty's name
Rusty's like well, I didn't know if you
guys want to keep meeting. He's like, well, yeah, we're disciple
are we I mean so you can
see the battle in between the the spiritual child
and spiritual young adult the disable maker and
it's like I don't really like the way this is going to go but so I just
want you to see this is the way that discipleship works.
I wish it were simple. I wish you were scratching sniff. Oh
how easy it's not right, but
guess what happens?
I then I see let's say
well, let's let's meet again next week. Let's let's do
it again. And then I send Rusty of
private text message. I said Rusty. I'm so proud of you.
For not giving up on those guys.
For realizing that you're gonna be an intentional leader
and that you're going to do this even when it's not easy and
and then he sends me a text back
and he says you know, what yesterday Phil.
We used to meet on Tuesday mornings and they still do he said
bill.
Asked me do you think Phil would be proud of
what we're doing without him?
And I told Bill I think Phil would
be real proud of what we're doing because we haven't quit and we're
not going to quit and then the very next day. This is
if the Holy Spirit was involved some
How very next days like how are we not meeting?
And he says yeah, we're going to keep meeting.
And so what I'm asking you guys to do is think in
terms of who is God calling you to invest
your life in.
Who?
Have you been praying that prayer I've been asking
the Lord who who have you in your
Divine wisdom identified
for me to join forces
with and create a micro group. And and
I promise you this if you'll be serious asking God
what he would have you do and then you'll be obedient to
follow through with it. It's gonna be exciting. It's
gonna be easy. No,
Is it going to be messy probably?
Is going to be worth it. It literally is life-changing.
I sit down today at lunch actually at 2
o'clock, Joe Williams.
Joe are you here?
There's Joe in the back. I have to change my story now.
Connector and he met a guy at A discipleship meeting.
He says I need to mean he needs to meet Phil.
And so we got together today and we found out that
he and I have been studying the same kind of relational discipleship
making process from the same kinds of leaders for
a very long time. We've never met together. We have lots and
lots of mutual friends, but it was so amazing to listen
to the 67 year old man.
Just brimming with passion for God
changing lives in him getting to be a part
of it.
And to share that heart with him and to
one day be able to share that heart with so many of you.